if you want to go to Google right now
and type in how to be different you
would get roughly 2.9 billion searches
that would show up why because billions
of people wake up every single morning
saying how can I be different and be
authentic and unique now here's how
simple the answer to that question is
there's only one way for you and I to be
different permanently and that's to be
you see a lot of people we can watch
somebody and act like them even actors
can act like another person temporarily
but permanently they go back to be the
way they are you see if you watch
late-night shows right we have Carson we
have Johnny Carson we have Jay Leno we
have David Letterman we have Jimmy
Fallon Jimmy Kimmel they all do
fantastic jobs
some people like one more than the other
but they're all absolutely different in
their own styles and they've been
successful you don't need to be like
somebody to to have the kind of success
they've had however there's one thing to
keep in mind this is what we can do to
be slightly different and that is to
learn how to think different see when
you read a book like Atlas Shrugged by
Ayn Rand
Mark Cuban told me in Nashville
Tennessee that this is the book that
completely changed the way he viewed
things she challenged people how to
think different if you read this book
you're probably going to be thinking
different The Alchemist Paulo Coelho he
challenges you to think different rework
he talks about working in a complete
different way Jason free how to think
different you got this book here first
rate madness it challenges you how to
think different so when you think about
it read great books from great minds to
learn how to think different but stay
authentic and stay true to you because
that's the only way for you to be
different thanks for watching the
episode by the way if you missed last
week's episode I did a video on how to
stand out on social media as an
entrepreneur if you haven't had a chance
to watch it click on the link right next
to me to watch the episode